next js is a popular open source react
front end
and this is a great beginner's course
cape does developer relations at
sanity.io
and she is an excellent teacher aloha
everyone my name is kapehe and welcome
to my intro to nxjs course so i've been
super curious about next js and if you
have as well
then we're all in the right spot now
together we are going to be learning
enough next to be able to continue on
and build out our own applications
so if you've worked with react in the
past then you know
that server side rendering is a huge
pain also
have you ever tried to configure your
webpack who has time for that i don't
but let me tell you about next it'll
take care of all that for us
this next js course will cover a number
of things so
our front end will be all the cool
features of next and what it has to
offer
we'll be looking at linking index and
even api routes with serverless
functions
we are going to be using an external api
to manage all of our content
and we will have real-time previews we
will accomplish
all of this with my favorite app idea a
recipe app so i picked a recipe app not
only because
i need a place for all of my recipes i
really like to cook
but also because next.js has a ton of
great features
that i feel we can cover with in a
recipe app
now people say that next is very
intuitive it's a very intuitive way to
build applications for the web
it's a react framework that takes away a
lot of the complexity like i was saying
earlier
that you would have to solve yourself if
you built something from scratch
i think you're going to really like it
and to pair nicely with next
we'll handle all of our content with
sanity.io
next doesn't come with a way to manage
content so we'll bring that in ourselves
but what sanity does for us is it gives
us a content link
so we can not only query for our content
but we can interact with it
sanity is free for projects like this
we'll explore that by adding a heart
button it'll be a little like button on
our recipe page
that uses an api route to patch the
recipe document
now once we have all of our next front
end pulling and content from the sanity
content link
we will use versailles where with zero
configuration
we can deploy our next app you can of
course deploy next js apps to pretty
much
any hosting platform that serves
websites and
finally we'll add real-time previews to
our next front end which is super useful
for editors who want to see their
changes before they go live
it's very nice to have now before we
start there are a couple of things that
you should have some knowledge on
first a little bit of javascript
knowledge is super helpful
second having worked with react
previously would benefit
a ton if you want to brush up on your
react knowledge you can follow a react
course
from free code camp now you can find me
on twitter at copay hey underscore okay
and with all that being said let's get
started all right
so next.js next.js is a react framework
for sites and apps for the web
so it comes with a lot of functionality
and we will talk about that
um in just a moment and also throughout
the building of our recipe app
but i just wanted to show you so next.js
if we scroll down a little bit there are
12 tiles that are titled y next.js
but there are a couple that i wanted to
really point out one for example is the
file system routing and we will show you
exactly how that is done and how next
does that
there is a really cool thing that when
you add a file it adds a route you don't
have to do
anything else um then there's like zero
configuration
to set it up there's image optimization
with an image tag
but all these great things come with
next js
and with next all of our pages will be
pre-rendered which is generally better
for
performance your user isn't having to
wait around while you're
while your application loads and it
generally is better for
seo as well so you get in front of more
users
and we will talk much more about these
in particular and i'll show you exactly
how they're done and how it looks
and more on that in a little bit all
right so before diving in there are a
couple
tools that we will be working with
throughout this course that i want to
make sure you have
up and ready or are prepared for them so
the first one is going to be vs code
that is going to be the text editor that
i will be using throughout this course
if there's a different text editor that
you prefer to use by all means
definitely use that but
i will be using this and if you'd like
to download it depending on
your machine you can download it at
code.visualstudio.com you will also need
a command line i will be using item
um it will look something like this um
you could use the terminal you could use
um any anything where you have a command
line
but we will be using a command line
throughout this
once we open up vs code i will be using
the terminal in there
and i will show you how to open that you
will also need
nodejs installed on your machine
so if you know js.org you can find the
download
options for whatever machine you are on
if you don't have this definitely get
this installed and if you already do
awesome so as i mentioned before you can
pretty much use anything you want with
nexjs
local markdown files any external api
and if you've built with react before
you may have used use effect
to pull in your external data and set it
to state which also is something that
happens client-side that is
in your browser so that's all happening
in the browser next
does it slightly different and i think
for
uh good reasons but it's usually better
to have all that content
ready for your next visitor right they
don't have to wait
what next less you do is return a
special function
and from the page template file this
handles the data fetching this
means we can do a lot of the heavy data
lifting when we deploy our site
to a hosting provider so we save our
visitors
the time to wait for the code to fetch
some external data
before they can get the content that's a
lot of waiting
and we don't want that so by default
next.js pre-renders every page
meaning next.js generates html and the
data files for each page in advance
instead of having it done client-side
javascript
so there's two forms of pre-rendering
that i want to talk about
static generation and server-side
rendering so static generation
is pre-run is the pre-rendering method
that generates the html
at build time server-side rendering is
the pre-rendering method that generates
the html
on each request so before it's served to
the visitor's
browser it's handled on the request and
then
serves it this is similar to what
happens in systems like wordpress
just think with javascript instead of
php
so we have our client set up and it's
ready to go
let's we're in the html file let's start
pulling in some data
we don't have any data to pull in from
sanity but i just want to show you all
what it looks like
so next allows you to pull in data in
different ways it does this by running
the special functions
that we export from the page template
file these functions will be run when we
build the site
but sometimes also if we have instructed
next.js to fetch
fresh data depending on the circumstance
but
yeah so the first function we want to
build out is get static props and we're
going to come all the way to the very
bottom
of this page and we're going to export
function get static props
open that up and then in here we're
going to do a return
all right so as implied by the name this
runs when you build and deploy your
next site so it's getting the static
props
what this function does is that it can
receive different parameters
and return what becomes our page's
properties props
see what they did there the data you're
returning will actually be saved to a
static json file which means
you have to return something that can be
turned into json
so next wants this object to have a key
called props so we're going to do props
and then you assign the data to
and we're going to do recipes because
we're going to be building out a recipes
app and we'll do title
pineapple smoothie
so we're going to save that all right so
now we have built out the get static
props ours when we start building out
the
the application will look a little
different but
same idea we have the props passing
through the data
and the data is recipes and we've given
it title
pineapple smoothie so we're going to
come up here to the top
of this file and here we need to pass
in our data so now it can be used
we're going to do const recipes is equal
to
data dot recipes and then
that's all we need here but let's use it
within our template let's actually
change out
this to b recipes
and we want to get the first instance of
it
dot title
awesome so let's see what that looks
like so we should now have a clickable
link that takes us to the about page
that's titled pineapple smoothie
and we do awesome so pineapple smoothie
is being pulled through
the get static props and we click on it
and it's doing what
what we told it to do with the link but
yeah that is what getstatic props will
look like and we will be using that
throughout this course so yeah so let's
get started on
setting up our sanity getting all our
data set up so we can
actually pull in our content all right
so
let's set up sanity sanity
let's go to that website let's check it
out
and all right so sanity it will replace
our need for
markdown files or even a cms because
it's a unified content platform meaning
that it comes with a lot of
apis tools capabilities that lets you
work and build
more freely with your content it also
specializes on what we call
structured content which means that your
content is more readily available to be
presented
wherever you need it so today we're
going to be building a web app but
maybe you want to build a native app for
your recipes too
it can be used across both of those so
what's neat with structured content is
that you aren't locked to a platform or
technology
you can use the exact same content in
all these places so we're going to build
out
one instance of our content and we can
use it across
many different platforms and
technologies so in the long run this
will save us time
if we need to change it because we
change it in one spot not in many
so more specifically sanity.io gives you
a real-time datastore
where you put your content as json
documents
more specifically sanity.io gives you a
real-time data store where you put your
content as json documents
and you can query it with a general
purpose query language like grok
which we will look at in a bit because
we will be using grock today
or you can use graphql so because sanity
lets you treat content as data
they call it the content link the
content link is where you can pour
pour all of your content and interact
with it in any way you need to
so sanity also lets you update and patch
these documents and access them
through an open source editing
environment called the sanity studio
which we will also be using
it really lets you treat your content as
data which unlocks a lot of
possibilities and cool uses
so if you know react like you have to
when building next.js
you can also customize the studio in all
sorts of ways because it's build and
react
um you can make the content any editing
experience
make sense for you you make it what you
need you customize it however
you can also upload images and files to
sanity and have them hosted on the
global cdn
for the images you can request custom
sizes or formats
from the one yes the one you
it upload one and use it across many
different sizes
so you can query on the metadata on the
dimensions
or even the color palette of the image
so you can use the color palette to see
what would be like a good foreground
color for accessibility which is really
awesome so sanity's apis are hosted so
you don't have to worry about
uptime and availability and it's free to
use for projects
that don't have a lot of traffic or a
lot of advanced needs
so it'll be perfect for our application
today
you can create as many free projects as
you want on sanity.io
and pay as you go if you have overages
or your
business is growing that's great and you
need more than the quota includes
so let's set up our first sanity
project together all right so
there's many places we can go seated
you can click on getting started or
another spot sanity.ios starters
so here you can find community
and official starters that have been
created
awesome stuff angular next i see next
11t gatsby so there's plenty of starters
that you can pick from here
but because we are starting from scratch
we don't need any of these starters
we are going to click on get started
this little button
and here we have the official starters
again those were in that list
that we just looked at but i want to pay
attention to this line right here
let me zoom in so npm install globally
the sanity cli because we need that and
sanity init so sanity init is going to
initialize a project for us so i'm going
to copy that
and i'm going to go back to my project
let's
add
pull this up let's add a terminal
because we need that
and here i'm going to just paste in that
command that we just copied and hit
enter so it's going to install the
sanity cli
and it's going to ask us to log in so
whatever you choose here
google github email password combination
remember it because it's going to ask us
to
ask us again and we need to choose the
same one so i'm going to do github
it's going to authorize me login is
successful let's go
back and right away we have create new
project so the sanity init part of that
command
was just initialized so i'm going to hit
enter because yes we want to create a
new project
let's name it studio
and default data set yes we want that so
y
and then hit enter and then that is the
correct path just double
check and then here we can choose a
schema that has sample data or just a
schema
but we want clean project with no
predefined schemas
because we are going to build out our
schemas so it's going to be building
that out for us
all right so it's done so sanity init
it initialized our new project for us it
brought in a project id
and the data set for all of our
documents and it created a brand new
folder for us called studio that was the
name that we gave it so if we gave it a
different name like
my studio it would say my studio right
here um
so yeah it's gonna set up the studio and
we are now
able to customize and configure it
locally so the first thing i want to do
is i want to get our studio
up and running so i'm going to cd into
studio
and then i'm going to run the command
sanity start
sanity start is going to run our
studio locally at localhost 3333 let's
run that
and it might still be building it
awesome so like i said whatever you
picked
before make sure you pick here so i did
github so i'm going to click github
otherwise it would have like an
authentication error that an authorized
yada yada all right so here's the name
this is to create new document here is
our desk and our vision
i'm zoomed in a bunch but if i zoomed
out those would pop
up but because i'm zoomed in it creates
that um my avatar would be over here as
well
there it is and yeah there's no
schema so let's go create them so again
we're not
mapping this content to pages per se but
structuring it after what it
is and means so sanity lets us combine
the content in any way that we want
which means we can let next js take care
of the web page building which is
perfect
because next.js is really good at doing
that so we will get the content ready
and let next.js do its magic
so the way we want to structure our
content in the studio is by making
relatively simple
javascript objects that describe the
document types
and the fields that we want to have
available so
there are plenty of fields that we can
choose from but let me pull
this down let me go back to the code so
in studio
this is our new folder
in here we have config node modules
plugin schemas
all this great stuff now
i wanted to point out sanity sanity.json
and here we have our project id
this project id is very important for us
connecting our next app
to our sanity app so
we'll find that here and in a little bit
we're going to be needing this
so it's important to know where that is
and we also need to know
where this is but we chose that when we
did the sanity init
now in here we have schemas schema.js
is where all of our schemas that we
create will be
imported into and used so we will visit
this
this file a good amount as well
and then plugins we won't be using node
modules
make sure that this is get ignored and
it is
not so let's go to git ignore
and all you need to do is remove that
forward slash
hit save come back here refresh that
and now it's 19 because we don't want
5000.
so that's what we need to do there okay
so the schemas that we want to build out
for this app
there's three of them we want to do chef
ingredient and recipe so chef and
ingredient
recipe will be referencing those
individually
so referencing is going to be happening
a bunch
in our schemas and referencing is fun
because you don't have to rewrite
content you don't have to rewrite
anything you just reference it once
and then the schema that you built out
it takes all that data and it can use
all of it
so let's build out our first schema
let's do a new file
and we'll do chef.js
okay so with schemas we're going to
export
default open that up and we'll do name
chef title chef
and type document
so it's always going to have a name
title type
name is like the name of it title is
the studio facing name of it and then
type as document
sanity has many different schema types
this one is document let's go to
schema types
so here it's a little too big
schema types here's a list of all the
schema types
so document was the one that we just
used document is
everything in the studio starts with a
document so the document is created and
then
all the other types live inside the
document type
so the three schemas that i
mentioned earlier are all going to be
document types
and then if you scroll down each one
will have examples
like type document and then the output
of it
some others that we're going to be using
array block
image string text so
if you want to continue and you want to
use other ones that we're not using
today
click into it and you'll find a little
image of it what it's going to look like
in the studio
but then also the properties options
and then code examples of it so
definitely check that out if you want to
add more
to your studio one that i really want to
point out is reference
so reference because we are referencing
our
types our document types from recipe
we're going to be referencing chef
from recipe we're going to be
referencing ingredient
so relations between documents are
modeled using the reference
type so the model is a one-to-many
relationship because it's
one thing getting all the all the
content in the one
document type and there's different
properties we can have on it
weak hidden read-only but i want to show
you down here
what it's going to look like so we're
going to have a type of reference and
it's going to reference directly to
so if we had recipe recipe would
reference to
ingredient so that's what it would look
like then the output would be
this there's many different ways to do
it you can do multiple
and then i wanted to show the grok way
to grab it right here so when we write
our grot query and we are
using a reference this would
de-reference it
and pull out everything from that person
so there are different ways we can do it
we will be doing all of that
in this so stay tuned
all right so i'm going to get out of
this let's go back here
let's come out of that and so now we're
going to have to do
a fields array
with all of our different types
and i need to comment after this all
right so i'm going to do
name name title type name is going to be
name title is
chef's name and
type is going to be string save that
and come out of that we'll do
name is image
title image
type is image and then we're going to do
an options on this
that is hot spot is true
i will show you what hot spot is in one
moment but
it's very nice to have hot spot true on
there so be sure to put that in
now i'm going to come out of that and
we're going to do another one
we'll do name is bio
title is bio
and type is array
so already we have three different four
different
schema types in this uh in this chef.js
so open up that type and we're gonna do
dove
open that up and we'll do title is block
we'll do type is block
styles will have
title is normal
and the value is normal
and then lists is an empty array so list
will be a drop down of predefined
values so we're gonna put that there all
right so now that is all written out
let's explain what's happening there's a
lot going on right now
so i'm gonna save this so document type
everything starts with a document type
insanity within that we have our fields
array
this is going to be an input where you
can put in a string
chef's name this is going to be an image
now this
this array with type block is
type block is our portable text
so this is creating for us a portable
text editor so for the bio field
we do want to have rich text that is
text you can add things
like emphasis lists headings and so on
but we don't want people to go full
overboard with text markup in the bio
field it should be simple and neat
so as i mentioned earlier sanity is all
about treating content as data
that goes for rich text as well so we
will not
store our rich text as markdown or html
but it's a format
called portable text this will actually
make it simpler for us to use
inside of our react templates too
because we were able to render it
directly to react components
and we don't need to inject or parse
html so without going too far into it
portable text
will store your rich text as json and if
it's stored in json that means you can
query it with grok
and that's really cool so for example
you can query all of your documents that
has more than three emphasized spans if
that's something you're interested in
you can query for that or if you have
added a custom recipe block as part of
your blog content
you can query for specific blog posts
containing
such and such reference to a certain
recipe too
so it makes everything even more
queriable
so to add a portable text editor in the
studio you add an array
like we did here and put a block field
inside of it so with this what the
studio sees
is a block type inside of an array
it will turn the array field or a field
into a rich text editor so now this is
our rich text editor
and furthermore you can also customize
the editor so if we want to simplify the
out of the box editor
we can add a bit of configuration to
remove some of the options like what
we've done here
now let's see what this all looks like
in the studio
and then i want to show you what this
really looks like in the studio
so that's all saved something i need to
do is i need to go to schema.js
and i need to import chef from
chef and then use it down here
save that and if we go here it should
have chef
so we click on chef no document of this
type found
because we haven't added anything and
here we have
our and i'm going to collapse these by
clicking on them here we have our entire
schema for chef now we have chef's name
it's just a string so i'm just going to
write my name in let's bring in
an image it is an image of me
and my bunny bonnie
and then bio here we're going to do
is from is is a chef
from las vegas nevada
all right so then we're going to publish
that and i want to show you
what edit details does so this is the
hot spot is
true thing that we did so if we click on
this this hotspot and crop comes up i'm
going to just go
a little bit so here is the crop
and here is the here is the hotspot
so because i'm the chef i want to make
sure
people know i'm the chef and not bonnie
so i'm gonna put emphasis on me to make
sure that
everyone knows it's me
just like that and that can be really
zoomed in on me
that's okay though let's make another
chef
and we'll do bonnie and this time
we really want to emphasize
bonnie so we're going to really cut me
out
and we're going to really emphasize
bonnie the bunny
so using one photo i'm able to
across different aspect ratios use that
same photo but
always make sure that whatever my hot
spot is on is always going to be in view
so if i i mean if i changed
this and i put on my face see how it
changes
so yeah it makes it
really great for not having to upload
many images
for many different aspect ratios um but
yeah that is hotspot
and crop there's bonnie
and then we'll say bonnie is a chef
who loves to use carrots
and then we're gonna do carrot emoji and
i'm pulling this emoji thing up by
hitting command control
spacebar on mac hit publish
and now we have two chefs bonnie and
kapeh
so uh yeah now i want to show you what
it would look like if i got rid
of this rich text editor so i wanted to
talk just a little bit more on this
array type
so because i put block in here
it is an array of blocks like
with the rich text editor if i got rid
of it this is what would happen
so i'll do a type of um
title is
bio um name bio i should have
capitalized that title
and then type will do string so if i
save that
and i go back to the studio we had that
block when okay
so because it was blocked that we put in
before it's
kind of erroring out because it used to
be block but if i wanted to add an
item now it's just an array of a string
so
hi um add another item
this is a string in my array
so that's what it would look like but
because we did block
remove that changes back
to block get rid of this string
and now we should have our rich text
editor pop back up and it's
happy because it's now back to block but
that is what's happening so it's an
array and you can do an array of
lots of different schema types but when
you do block and then it creates this
rich text editor where we can type in
all of our content
so here you can have your bio super long
and you can just keep writing about all
the chef awards that you've gotten over
the past years
so but yeah with that being said
you add a block to the array and we have
our rich text editor
publish that i think this one
yeah publish that
all right so now that we have chef all
set up and me and bonnie are chefs
let's go and let's create our next
schema so the next one we're going to
create is ingredient so i'm gonna go to
schemas
new file ingredient.js
and same thing export default open that
up
name ingredient
name title
ingredient and type is
you guessed right document type we're
going to do a fields
array and open that up and our first one
is going to be title
or name is
name title is
ingredient name
and type is string
come out of that let's do another one
we'll do name is image
title is image
and type is image and we're going to do
again the option for
hotspot is true
great and then come out of that and one
more
we'll do name is notes
title is notes
and type is text save that
and we need to come to our schema and
bring in
import ingredient from
ingredient and then we have to use it
down here save that let's come back
an ingredient should pop up all right
let's make some ingredients
so let's add a new one for our first one
let's do pineapple
we will upload a picture
of pineapple and i don't want to hotspot
or crop this so i'm just going to keep
it how it is
but if i had a big picture and i wanted
to crop it down to this that's what i
would do
notes now i wanted to put notes in here
because
this doesn't need all this content does
not need to go on the front end and this
is not going to go on the front end this
is just notes
for us as owners of the studio to always
remember
and when you cook sometimes it's great
to have notes on
ingredients where you get them what you
like what you don't like
if you like a certain brand that kind of
stuff so this is just internal notes for
us
so i'm going to write um
i like to get my pineapples
at the local i can type local
farmers market it happens
every second
saturday of the month so notes for me
um so when i come into my studio it's
kind of like a little diary of my
of my recipes so we're going to publish
that and let's
let's make another ingredient when we
will do
mango we will drop in
a pitcher of yummy
mangoes and then we'll do notes
um a notes about mangoes uh
the seeds are really hard to get out
and if you've ever tried to get out the
seed of a mango
i mean it's really hard so
that is the truth all right so we have
mango and we have pineapple
so our last schema that we need to do is
recipe
and let's create new file recipe.js
and this one remember is going to be
referencing the other two that we just
made
so export default open that up
and we'll do name recipe
oops name recipe title
recipe and type is
document open up our fields
array
open that up and forgot a comma
and there we go all right so the first
fields
object that we want is name
so we're going to name
title is recipe name
and type is
string then we're going to do
a slug we're going to need slugs later
on
especially for our front end name is
slug title slug
type there's a type slug
and then under that we're going to do
options
so the source is going to be the name
whoops and then the max length
is 96 so if you're
if your slug is longer than 96
and then we're referencing this name
cool
let's come out of that and let's make
another one
and we'll do name
chef we've seen this before somewhere
do we want to reference it i think so
title
chef type ooh
type is reference like we saw in the
docs
and we're going to reference two
so we don't have to type out a whole
nother schema we're just going to reuse
type is chef so it's going to
go right to chef and then
next we're going to do name is
main image and we'll do
title is recipe
main image type
image and then we'll do options
of course for hot spot is true
and then we'll come out of that and
all right so we're gonna do another
array but this array is not going to be
block so we're gonna open that up we're
gonna do name is ingredient
we'll do title ingredient
i always want to do a colon after the
that
okay and then type is array
and then type is array
awesome okay and then we're going to do
of
open that up type
is going to be object and
fields open that up again
here okay so what this is going to be is
a modal we're going to click on like add
to like add something
and it's going to open up and it's going
to be referencing
something the ingredient it's going to
be giving us option for a number
an option for a string which we're going
to create a
list of an array of strings
so there's going to be a lot going on in
this little modal but
i will walk through all of it with you
so name
ingredient
title ingredient
and type is a reference because we don't
want to write it all again
we're just going to reference straight
to
and you guessed it type ingredient
awesome so let's come out of that the
next part of the model so we're going to
have an ingredient
first item in the modal
next is going to be whole number
title whole number
and type is going to be a number
so if you can kind of guess what we're
doing is an ingredient is put into a
recipe
and you can choose how much of something
so whole number we're going to do next
fraction and then unit so come out of
this
so the next one is name
fraction title
fraction type
we will do a string string for this
string and then we're going to do
options because we want to create a list
for these strings or a list drop down
options list is going to be an array
of strings half cup or
half fraction one-third
one-fourth
three-fourths and you can put as many as
you want
i'm just gonna stop right here so that
is my drop down
so i've i've assigned what my strings
are
so it's like hard-coded um these are the
only fractions that you can choose on
the front end
or the studio front end and yeah let's
come out of that
and let's create one more kind of just
like that
so name is unit
title is unit
type is string
options same thing and we're going to do
list an array of
grams cup
capital t for tablespoon and lowercase
t for teaspoon
i'm gonna save that let's go look at it
i missed something oh ow we did not add
it to
schema so schema come in here you need
to
import recipe from
recipe and use it down here
awesome all right let's go look at it so
recipe so if we click on this no
documents here have been created
we'll click on that and now we have i'm
going to collapse these just so we can
see all this
our schema that we've created so recipe
name
uh pineapple smoothie
generate the slug from that name chef we
can type to search
or we can choose one of them here
um we'll give bonnie credit for this
and then i have an image
over here of a
pineapple smoothie yeah and
we can edit the details if we want to
really make sure this pineapple is
uh the hot spot we'll do that now
ingredient add items we're going to
click on this
and it's going to bring up a modal for
us this is the reference
this is the number these are the two
lists that we made
so ingredient we can do drop down or we
can just start typing we need pineapple
we need two and a half
cups of pineapple okay
so we're going to exit out of that and
look at this
so notice how it says half we want this
preview to look a little
better we don't want to say half we want
to have
maybe a picture of the ingredient uh a
title
and and like a subtitle with like how
many of the ingredient we want
so we want to change this now sanity has
a way to do that
and i will show you how so come back to
the code back to
ingredient no recipe and down here below
the array we're going to write preview
open that up and we are going to select
certain items that we want to use
so title ingredient dot name
name ingredient dot name
um media will be ingredient
dot image so we'll be using the image
and then we'll do whole number is
whole number
and then fraction is fraction
and unit is unit so we're pulling those
out to be able to
select them and use them so here we are
dotting
into the targeted thing so we wanted
ingredient
but we want the name for the title same
thing
so we're just grabbing the content that
we want to be able to use
now underneath select we want to run a
prepare
let me show you exactly what is going to
be happening here
so prepare we're going to pull out the
title subtitle media
whole number we're going to equal that
to
something because what if we don't have
a whole number what if we're only using
like half of something
so if there's no whole number we'll say
no
whole number set
then we'll do fraction same thing we
might not have a fraction set so we want
to write
no fraction set
and then last one is unit
and we'll do no
unit set okay and then there's one last
section
and after this we'll go we'll talk about
this way more so we're going to open
this up
to a return and this return
is going to be using what we just set in
that prepare
so title subtitle which we want the
subtitle to be
whole number
and then fraction
and then unit
and then underneath this we want media
so when it comes to
preview prepare and return we're
generally going to be using title
subtitle media and i'll show you because
it looks very nice
so i'm going to save that
and here now it looks nice now there's
an
image the pineapple is the
title and two and a half cup is the
subtitle
if we wanted to add um more pineapple
but we didn't want to do a whole number
we just needed half
a cup
no whole number set half cup so that's
what it would look like um and then
just so you know you can move these
around if needed
now let's look at sanity preview
so here sanity will often need to render
a representation
of a document or an object so what we're
doing is we're
previewing we're showing a
representation of something we've
already created
it's called a preview so we decide what
fields should be used
again like i said generally title
subtitle and media
take the cake so
here we have a
schema laid out and the preview they
selected title
and subtitle as title here
and release date here
so here let's look at the prepare so
above title and release date are
selected
but the result of the selection is past
the prepare
where you can transform the selection
however you like
so in this case
split they're modifying it to be only
the year
so the whole year comes out but we just
want just the first part of that
so that's where you can tweak it however
you need what we did
is we set it like this and then
it knows if there's nothing there to
grab it will return
no unit set or whatever
and yeah there's a lot that you can do
with this preview and prepare
um what we're doing is a good start
and it makes the studio side of this
look very good i think um so yeah
let's add something let's get rid of
this pineapple and let's add
mango because it's a pineapple smoothie
we don't need tons of mango
so we'll do a fourth cup of mango
okay now when you have a recipe yeah you
can have ingredients and a picture and a
title and a chef but you need
instructions
so we need to add one more thing so
we're going to come back here
and under
this after the array after the object
right here
we're going to do one more and it's
going to be
name instructions
title
instructions and type will be
array of
and i'm making a rich text editor by
doing
type block
i'm gonna save that
and let's go look we should have a rich
text editor and sure enough we do
so this is us being able to like
fold it italicize it underline but here
i'm going to write
put all ingredients into a blender
blend on high for
one minute serve
chilled nice okay so now all of our
content is in here
and now we can take this content and put
it on our front end
but i want to show you something real
quick so here we have
a string we have a slug we have a
reference we have an
image we have an array of
these objects and we have an array of
blocks
let me show you what it looks like so if
you click on these three little dots and
you click on inspect
this is what our data looks like parsed
raw json
either way you want to look at it but
our data is returned as json so this can
be used
all over so ingredient unit
whole number all of our information
is here our slug what our current slug
is
instructions is going to be block and
because we have
multiple blocks because i created
multiple blocks we have the children
that has the text in them so put all
ingredients to a blender next blocks
next block blend on high for one minute
next block
surf chilled now see how all these don't
have any mark defs
and they're all style as normal let me
show you what it looks like if i change
one
sort of chilled we really want to make
sure you serve this chilled some
italicize that
don't forget don't serve it hot we're
going to come back to inspect
come to the bottom and
serve chilled now has the em marks
so emphasis
and that's what it would look like if i
did bold
let's do this bold because we want to
make sure people
really know blend out high for one
minute same thing
and now it has strong
so the marks for this strong marks for
this
is the italics that emphasized
so yeah that's what our content looks
like and
we have all of our information here
here's the parsed version of it
main image all the content
lives here and yeah now
now that we have all that set up let's
start pulling it to the front end let's
start setting up our next app
and let's get rolling with building our
application
all right so we do need to connect our
sanity app
to our next app so first we'll make a
sanity.js
file and we'll put it into a folder
that's called lib we don't have to call
it lib but just because of convention
we're going to call that
so we're going to create new folder
we'll do lib and within lib we'll do a
new file
and we'll do sanity.js all right so the
first thing we need to do is we need to
install the next sanity toolkit
so this will come with hooks and
functions that are useful
when we build with sanity so let's
actually look at the next
sanity um github repo so we'll do next
sanity right here okay here we will see
what it comes with some of the features
so client-side live real-time preview
for authenticated users
um url helper for sanity's image
pipeline we'll use that
um rich text component for portable text
again using that um but here we'll see
how to install it
we'll get the real-time preview which we
will be doing that
as well um but yeah here we'll just get
more information on what
comes with the next sanity toolkit
we will also be bringing in our project
id
and our data set into this file and i'll
show you how to do all that
we'll import the things that we need and
export the things
that we need to use throughout the app
so you can find out
all the information here but let's go
back to our
code okay so the very first thing we do
need to do is install the toolkit let's
actually
go back to this let's look at the
command we need to do
up up up right here so npm installed
next sanity
this is what we're going to use you can
also use the
yarn version but yeah you have both
options okay let's go to one
terminal that's not running anything and
we will paste in that npm install
next sanity so we will let that install
and all right so now the package has
been installed and we can
just keep that down we'll just go back
to yeah
all right so now let's import it and
let's import all the things that we need
from this next sanity so like we showed
in the github repo if you want to learn
more about like the performance of the
ones that we're going to be using
definitely check out this github repo
that will have all that
that information um but let's just talk
briefly about the things that we are
going to be using
and then once we do use them then we'll
talk more about them and see how they
actually work
so we're going to do import open that up
and we're going to do create client
we're going to import
create preview subscription
hook create
whoops create whoops image url
builder and then create portable
text component all right
and then this is all going to be from
next sanity all right so let's export
these
so we'll come down and the first one
we're going to export will be export
const sanity client and then equal that
to
create client and then in here
we need to use our project id
so rather than writing out the project
id
and the data set every time we want to
export one of these let's
actually do const config is equal to
project id and we'll equal that to
something in a little bit we'll do data
set
leave that blank for now api version
for blank blank for now and then use
cdn and we'll set that to true so let's
talk about all these
let's get that information so that um we
don't have to write it
over and over down in the exports so
project id and
data set if we go into studio and we go
into
sanity.json we will find
our project id and our data set so i'm
just going to copy this project id and
then
remember production for data set
so let's go back paste that in
and data set production so with a
project id you can consider this
public so it goes into the url of the
apis that you're hitting
you can find it again like in the senate
sanity.json that we
saw and you can also find it in your
manage dashboard
which i will show you in just a minute
and then with our data
data set name we picked production when
we did the sanity init
and again find that in the sanity.json
so let's move on to the api version so
api version
is going to be 2021 03-25
so sanity's api is versioned so that
sanity can push out new features and
fixes
without breaking anyone's stuff so we're
going to put in
this api version and let me show you
where you can find out more information
on that
i'm gonna go here under api versioning
in the docs so yeah and here we'll
you'll learn everything about how to
handle versioning with the sanity api
uh if you want to learn more about that
definitely check out this doc
but we are going to put into our api
version
2021 325. and lastly with our ucdn we're
actually going to change this to false i
put true
just for the time being but we're going
to have that be false so you can choose
if you want to pull from the cdn that is
the global cache network
um or directly from the real-time
content link
we recommend using the cdn in a
production environment but on local it
can make sense
for this to be set to false so you don't
need to wait for those minutes for the
latest changes
so for now we're going to set it to
false if you want to change it to true
definitely go ahead and do that and now
we can finally pull in
our config here and it will be using all
of that for us
now let's work on the remaining of our
exports
so next we're going to export const
we'll do use
preview subscription equal that too
we'll do the create preview subscription
hook and we'll use the config
the next one will be export const url
four now in the url four we are going to
be
setting a source so the source let me
put it in
the source we'll be using create image
let me just type this all out builder
using the config and then chaining on
image
source all right so source in the url
for
is the asset data that we're clearing
from the content link so this is the
image
asset data the asset data that we are
querying for we need to make sure we
pull that in
so that is why we use source right there
and then our last one
is export whoops
export const portable
text and set that equal to create
portable text no yeah portable text
component
and then open that up and we're going to
do dot dot
config to copy that and then serializers
and then an empty object now we will be
using
all of these throughout this course so
we just wanted to get it set up so that
as we start using them across files
it's already been exported and yeah so
the last thing we need to do
before we can start building out our
next app is
setting up course so coors controls from
which domains a browser can do requests
to your content like so enabling
authentication will allow requests that
uses your token information
from your logged-in cookie so you really
want to make sure you can only
deploy code to the domain that you
enabled this for
so course isn't needed to do server-side
requests it's only for browser so
client-side
because we typically don't use cookies
on server side we use tokens which we
will look at later we will be using a
token
now there are different ways we can set
up cores
um one of them to come down here we can
go to a new
terminal and we could do
sanity cores add and we can do http
and then type out whatever the url is
but let me show you another way
so we'll keep that down and if we go to
our manage dashboard we will see
how we can add cores and i'll also show
you all the other things in the manage
dashboard so if we come up here we go to
manage
sanity.io
all right so here are all of our
projects here's our dashboard
now the last three studios i've named
are all the same name i highly recommend
not doing that and
doing a unique name for each one because
now which one do i pick
no i do know which one it is it's my
most recent one right here
i click on it project id right here
remember we found it insanity.json
so here's our project id let's make sure
it matches up h
a j up here aj
awesome now throughout here we see like
the usage
so we're on the free free version
so everything's zero but uh if
you added to this this is where you
would see it you can invite project
members members would also be under here
but you can add people to this so they
have
like access to it data sets usage so
what your usage looks like
and then settings this is where we're
trying to go so if we click on settings
and here we'll just see general settings
the name of it i could rename this
um different things but here we're
trying to find
course origins so we're going to click
on add course origins
and we have our
allowed one which is localhost 3333
and here we would add in the url
um i've already typed it in before so
that's why you see that drop down
but pretend like we haven't so localhost
3000.
so we want localhost 3000 to be able to
have credentials so course origin
settings
is saying what control from which
domains browsers can do requests to
the content link so we're letting sanity
know
that localhost 3000 can make requests
to our content link and we will be using
that
in a moment but we want to set it up now
so we didn't have to worry about it
something we have to remember is when we
deploy this
we have to bring that url that is our
deployed url
and bring it in here and add it to the
course origins
now the last thing we need to do is
click allow credentials and
hit save and we have now localhost 3000
and localhouse
localhost 3333. both of these
are under course origins and both can
make requests and
yeah now with all that being said
this is all set up and the next thing
we're going to work on
is the app.js file so
let's get rolling on that okay so now
that we have next
talking to sanity let's actually start
building out our next
files so we're going to come under pages
and we're going to go to app.js so this
file encompasses our entire app
so we're going to keep it as is and just
add to it
so i know we are going to want link
import link from next link and then
we're going to come down here
open this return up
and bring it down here
and then we're going to wrap this whole
thing in a
react fragment save that
and i do know that we want to wrap this
component
in a main tag because this is going to
be our main
section of our app still because this is
our page props and it's bringing
all the information in and displaying it
i do want to add
an entire i do want to add a nav bar
to our entire app that's why i'm going
to build it here because i want it to
show up on every page
it's going to be just one thing that
takes us home it's not going to be a
very
fancy navbar but i did want to make sure
we added that in
okay so underneath this we're going to
add
nav and then a div within that
that has we're going to be using link
that has an a tag inside
now the a tag i'm going to do cap's
kitchen
and let's add a
pineapple yeah
and then in the link we need to add an
href
that is taking us back home
and that is it so we should now have
a yeah cap's kitchen takes us back to
the home page if i'm i mean i guess i
can click somewhere else and it's always
going to be there takes it back
awesome okay now all we want to do
is add styling so i do know in this nav
i do want to add a class name of
header i'm going to save that and all of
our
css is going to live in this global css
down here let's empty this out
now when you have styling it is always
good to
normalize your css because when you send
your
app to um a browser sometimes there's
applied styles from the browser so if we
kind of cancel all those out
we can make sure that that's not
happening to us so
i'm going to search for normalized css
cloudflare
and i want to copy this link
yeah let's go back here and let's do at
import url
and we'll put the link right in there oh
right like that so now all of our css
styling will be
correct and whatever browser someone's
using won't be changing any of that
so we just created the header
in here we want to do max width
width of 80
we'll do a margin of 0 and auto
we'll do padding of 12 pixels and 10
pixels so
on all sides and a font size
of 25 pixels i also
know that i want to style the a tag
within header so we'll do header
a open that up color
okay i want to pick like a green color
let's do green i like it
i get darkish green yeah let's try that
okay so that's my color um display we'll
do
inline block padding
top we will do 10 pixels and
text decoration we want none because we
don't want that
underline that comes with that
and we have that main tag that was
wrapped around
our in app.js
so let's do main so max
width width is 80
so it matches that nav bar and
margin 0 auto
padding top of
30 pixels and padding
bottom of 80 pixels
save that okay so we do want to add
a body so that a lot of this can be
just encompassing all of our application
so we'll do font family and we'll just
do
ariel yeah and you can choose any font
you want i'm just going to go with that
one for now
and then we'll do a background color
of yeah it's like a light gray
i'm going to save that and we should
have some nice styling
but index.js is not like done so it's
just kind of like
background end of navbar
let's get rid of this normalize there we
go
yeah so there's cap's kitchen and if i
went
and i navigated away it's always going
to be there and it always takes me back
so yeah that's what we have so far all
right so now that we
have our navbar our app.js file set up
let's work on our slash page so our
index.js
file so i'm in it right now and we've
done
some stuff in it already let's clean out
all of the content that was given to us
when we did the next uh
create next app command okay and then
we'll get rid of this because we're
going to update that
so really we're just starting fresh from
beginning we will need this um
but we will change it a bunch so i'll
just leave it there for now
and we don't need this
we will use link we don't need this
cool okay so starting from the top
we do need to import our sanity client
stuff so we're going to do sanity
client and we're going to pull in url
for
from and it's to
yeah lib and insanity perfect save that
all right so now we are going to be
getting into grok
so we are going to be pulling in our
content
using the query language grok
let's go learn more about it together so
grok sanity
all right so it is a query language
that was made by sanity and there's tons
of different like
examples there is a how-to section
um this is a really awesome doc it
starts off introduction
basic sorting but
yeah i definitely highly recommend
looking through this
and one that we will use
a lot is
this dereferencing because we are
referencing and i kind of showed you
that in that
um referencing doc but yeah you will see
that
here and we have
let me show you the cheat sheet
i like the cheat sheet a lot of just
like examples
and what would come out of it so
the asterisk gets you everything so
it's everything in our content like of
content
so it pulls everything and then this we
will start
filtering through what we want to pull
out
and then you can modify greater than
uh not equal to this or whatever but
yeah there's definitely lots of ways you
can use grock
and we will be using a number of ways to
get our content
but yeah let's go back to
our code so here we're going to set
const recipes query
two okay so here we're going to write
our first graph
query together um like we saw
in the doc the asterisk pulls in all of
our content
so it is our content lake of data
and we always start with asterisks
then we're going to open up with square
brackets and do underscore
type is equal to
recipe now this
type is equal to recipe is going to pull
all of
the content here so this is our type
that is recipe
and if we wanted to where is it
if we wanted to see what this returns we
could
you know continue coding or there is a
spot where we can
have a grok playground with our own
content
so let me show you that so i copied that
if we come to our studio we have
this is our desk view let me zoom out
just a little bit
so we can see so this is our desk view
if we go to vision
here is our grok playground for
our content i'm going to zoom in just a
little bit so this is where it will
where you can play and put in grout
queries for your content there is a
place where you can go
grok.dev where there's going to be
content already for you
you can play around with the queries and
hit play and this is what's returned
so this is just a generic
bunch of content but for our local
version
this is what we use and here i'm going
to actually change the api version to be
what we put in our sanity.js file
so we're going to do the this version
right here
and it ran for us all right so here is
what we get when we run the query type
equal to recipe we have one item and it
is
our pineapple smoothie here's the name
let's say we wanted to pull the name out
we would open that up and type in name
run that query and we get just pineapple
smoothie
um if we take that away
let's actually add another recipe so we
can have two
to kind of query up i'm going to go back
to desk and let's add
let's add a mango smoothie mango
smoothie
generate that slug and who was the chef
for last one
it was bonnie okay so i'm gonna take
credit for this one
and then let me pull in an image
this is going to be pineapples or mango
smoothie
and then we come down here and we're
going to add
a mango of one
cup awesome and then we'll say
blend mango with ice
serve chilled awesome so let's publish
that and let's go back to our vision
and remember if i just unzoomed a little
bit those would be up here but because
i'm zoomed in it creates that menu
so click there i'm gonna zoom back in
and now when we run this we should have
two items exactly there we go so there's
the mango smoothie and here is the
pineapple smoothie
and here's all the content that we are
getting back with just
the recipe so we are getting
the id the type recipe
uh the chef and this reference is the id
of the chef reference so if we did
so let's try and remember this reference
but yeah
four f e is it different than the other
one
yeah okay so 4fe
should be the pineapple smoothie chef
so if i did this
chef and we get 2 4fe
this reference is now the id of the chef
which is bonnie so bonnie was the chef
of that one
so it's referencing this id and then
pulling out all this
chef information for us so let's go back
to recipe and let's write out our entire
query that we want for
index.js so we want to pull out the
id we want to pull out the name
so here we see we want this id
we want this name we also want
the slug and the slug can be found right
here
pineapple.smoothie and then we want the
main
image and that is right here
and again this is referencing the id of
that image
and it's a type reference so let's run
this query
and here we go here's all the content
that we want for our
index.js so i'm going to copy this and
now that i know it's exactly
what we need i'm going to take it back
here
and i will paste it in right there
save that and now we have our query
all ready for index.js okay so we're
going to come down to the very bottom
and remember when we when we did this
get static props let's actually clean
this out
and put in the stuff that we do need
so remember get static props is going to
take in
the fetch so instead of like using a use
effect like with react
we're going to use this we're going to
fetch our data because we've written
this recipes query up here we're going
to use that
so here i'm going to do const recipes
equal to a weight
and we're going to add async up here
and then we'll do sanity client.fetch
and we're going to fetch for that
recipes query
and then we're going to return props
because we need props for all of this
and it's going to be set
to recipes
so we have okay so let's go over this
so the reason why we do the async await
on this get static props is that next.js
will pre-render this page at build time
using the props returned by this
getstatic props so that's why we add it
here
and then this line we're just assigning
recipes to that fetch
so all of our content that we are
getting in that recipes query
and then returning props as that content
so now that we've assigned props or
recipes to props we can use that
up in our
function so we're going to remove
this and now it's not data now it's
going to be recipes
we'll get rid of that and
let's write out our template and use our
content
so the reason why we have this in curly
braces is it's called a destructuring
assignment so what it does is it lets us
pick out values
inside of the object that is passed
through the home function
so instead of
i mean we could do we could do this so
we get rid of this
pass through props and then we could do
like const
recipes is equal to
props so we could do something like that
but instead
we can do the destructuring assignment
and
pass in recipes here and then
we can continue on okay so the first
thing i want to do is i want to update
the
tab so remember the head this title
is this tab intro to next so let's
update that
to say caps
kitchen and we will add a pineapple
yay and then underneath the head we will
start
with an h1 h1
and we'll do welcome welcome to
and we'll just do cap's kitchen here
and that's it for h1 and then let's open
this up
and we are going to do an unordered list
of all of
our recipes so what it's going to what
it's going to look like
is we're going to have our home page
we're going to have like caps kitchen
and then like welcome to cap's kitchen
and under that is going to be tiles that
are clickable
that has the main image and the title of
the recipe and then you click into one
it navigates you to
another page that we have not built yet
and that's going to have
all of our recipe content like
ingredients and instructions
but this we just want to display the
main image and the
title so let's do that so we're going to
do an unordered list
within that we're going to do list items
and within that we are going to link
with an a tag
that is set inside
that has set inside of it image
whoops i'll fix that and spam
awesome so in the unordered list
we are going to map over our content
so i'm going to open this up and if we
have recipes
so that question mark is if there are
recipes then continue on with this
then we want the length the amount of
the recipes to be greater than
zero and
once that is done then let's map
over all of that so we'll pass in
recipes a recipe
and then come out of this and we need
to take these three
and put them underneath the li
so now we have a map so we're doing an
unordered list
and mapping over the list items which is
going to be
images and names of the recipes
so link right now we're going to do an
href that is equal to
home because what we do want it clicking
to is not
built yet so let's just leave it at that
we'll come down to span
and let's do recipe.name
we'll save that and let's see
okay so we have welcome to cap's kitchen
but the content that we're pulling
through because this was hard coded and
so was this
is pineapple smoothie if we click on it
nothing will happen because remember
it's being
linked back to home
now let's add in the image so because we
were using the url4
we added that in our sanity.js file
because we're using that
we don't need to destructure the main
image and we can
use this to help us grab that url of
that main image whoops
so let's come down here and we're going
to image
source is equal to
url4 and will be recipe.main
image we'll come out of that and we'll
do dot url
now with this url4 we could continue
chaining on
so we could do it with we could set a
height but the most useful part of it is
this url
we is this url for so we don't have to
destructure up in our query
we can just pull out the main image and
this will take all of that
url destructuring work and handle it for
us
so that's what is happening there let's
save and we should have
our main image displayed for each one of
them
and we do okay so we have pineapple
smoothie
and we have mango smoothie very big
images but
let's style that so it looks nicer
so if we come here i think we have all
of that
in list items let's actually give a key
to each of these
so key will be
whoops the
recipe dot id
and then let's just work from the top
and let's style these out
so an ordered list we'll have a class
name
that we're going to name
um recipes dash list
and then we have on the list item
we have a class name that is equal to
recipe card
and that is it
yeah okay so
let's go style so all this will happen
in globals.css
come down here and
let's write out our css okay so we have
recipes
dash list open that up and we'll do
display
is grid grid
grid template template
columns we're going to do 1 fr
1fr 1fr so that's giving
three sections all equal space so
one one one and then we'll do a gap
between all those at 40 pixels we'll do
list
style is none and then padding
is zero then let's
go for recipe card and let's do recipe
card and the a tag of that
so we'll do display is block
height is 100 percent
text decoration is none now text
decoration now will take
off the underline for accessibility it's
not always the best
but make sure you make it obvious enough
that it's clickable
but if we kept this it would keep that
underline and that underline helps
people know that it is clickable so it's
up to you if you want to keep that or
not
so color we'll do hash 444 and then
font size will do 22 pixels
and then recipe card the image part of
it
recipe card image
we'll do height is 300 pixels
object fit is cover we want to
fill the entire space that is given
margin bottom
we want 12 pixels and then border
0.5 pixels solid and then hash 444.
save that and let's go see what it looks
like
so the only thing i don't like about
this is that this is wrapping so what we
need to do
is on image let's add display
block and there we go okay
so now we have two clickable areas
takes us nowhere takes us home but all
of this
is our tile and if we added another one
there'd be another one right here
and then if we added a fourth one it
would come down here
so it's ready to be filled with content
filled with recipes
all right so with that being said
all of that is what we need for index.js
and index.js is done
um and yeah now we can move on to
the slug js file and
this is where we are going to have when
someone clicks
on one of these where does it take them
it takes them to
the slug of where it takes them to the
page
of the recipe that we've clicked on so
let's get
to that okay so now that we have
app.js and index built out let's
build our dynamic route so the way next
does dynamic routes is and remember
all of our pages will live under pages
and we're going to create a new folder
called recipes to
organize and within recipes we're going
to do a new file
and to do a dynamic route we do square
brackets
slug because that's what we want to
replace
that name is the slug of the recipe
and this is our dynamic route
so it means that whenever we go to slash
recipes
whatever so like slash pineapple dash
smoothie
then we can access the last segment of
the url in our template file
and use that data for something for
example doing a query to fetch
a specific recipe in our case so
that's why we want a dynamic row here so
we don't have to do a route for
each recipe it will just know
replace the slug and whenever we access
this file
we are diving into it with the slug that
we want
and we will write out all that code so
it all makes sense
so for dynamic page templates like this
but we're going to be writing out
we can access the data from the url
inside of the get static props
so we will do get static props with
prams
and we'll do that and then we will
destructure the params
uh within our get static props so then
you can find the slug inside of params
that will set
and without talking about this let's
just code it up and let's look at what
it's all going to look like
so i do know we are going to need to
import a lot
from that
lib sanity
file so we will need the sanity client
of course we will need the url for
we will be pulling in that use preview
subscription
and portable text so all those things
that we made
in the sandy uh file are now
being used so we'll come out of here
and right away
we are going to have const recipe query
here
and this is where grock query is going
to live and then we'll do export
default function we'll call this
one recipe and then in here
we'll open that up this is going to be
our template
and all that good stuff and then very
bottom we will have
get we'll do
export async function get static
paths we have not seen that yet and we
will talk about that and then below this
we will do a export async function
get static static props
and there we go so
here is how our slug.js or dynamic route
is going to be
set up and yeah let's get working on it
so there are a couple things
in this that are going to be happening
so the use preview subscription we won't
be worrying about the sanity preview
till the end
um and that so that's just kind of
going to hang out for a bit the portable
text is going to be within our template
same with the url for and then the
sanity client is going to be whenever we
are
fetching our content all right so where
to begin
uh let's start with
writing out our grok query yeah let's do
that
so this query is going to be a little
different because we are
specifically looking for a slug
because that is everything in this
because we want to click on something
and go to only that slug display the
information there
so we're going to do the same thing
we're going to grab all of our content
asterisks grabs our content like
open up square brackets and we're going
to do type is
equal to still recipe
and slug dot current
is equal to the slug
and we're going to grab the first
item in that array so we are getting an
array of recipes
the first item the one that is clicked
on the current
slug is what we want displayed open that
up
and we want id we want name we want slug
main image so this looks very similar to
what we wrote
in the last file and we're going to
dereference that
and get the id and the url
now in addition to this so that's pretty
much the same stuff as last time
in addition to this we're going to also
grab the
ingredient
in that and we want everything from it
whole unit whole number fraction
ingredient let me pull this up
ingredient
and dereference that because remember
that is a reference to our ingredient
and pull out from that the name
otherwise we can't
get the name if we don't dereference it
because remember we didn't rewrite it in
the recipe we rewrote
we just referenced the ingredient and
then come out of that
and we will get instructions
all right so that is our entire
query getting the recipe the slug that
is clicked on
and all this content from it
cool so let's leave the one recipe for a
little bit and let's
work on get static paths and get static
props
so because we have a dynamic route that
uses
getstatic props it needs to define a
list of
paths that has to be rendered by next so
we want to tell next
hey here are all the paths that could be
clicked on
when it's clicked on then props will get
all of that content for us
so get static paths will allow
next to know all of the dynamic paths
so next we'll take all the paths that we
are giving it
and pre-render all of them so
getting it ready for the user so next.js
is going to want
params from this and we're going to tell
it slug
dot currents whatever slugs are made
available those are parameters we're
going to pass
those parameters to our get static props
and
it will pull out the content so in here
we want to open up get static paths and
we'll do const
paths is equal to await sanity
client.fetch because we want to fetch
all of and in here all
of the slugs that could be potential
paths
so we're going to open up a grok query
and we're going to do underscore type
is equal to recipe
and defined
slug dot current so this is going to
look for the slug dot current that
is going to be clipped on open this up
and
we want to set params
to slug
that is slug.current so
let's look at this for a second
so it's very different than the grok
query up here this is
getting a type of recipe select the
current but it's pulling out all the
content that we want this is
look is pulling out the path for
that content now we're going to take
this params
and we're going to bring it down here
but let me
not move on from get static paths let's
come out of this query
and we now need to return
the paths so we're fetching
all this setting it to paths now we're
returning it
and that return is going to be able to
be used
now we need to also do fallback and set
it to true
so if we set fallback to false then any
path
not returned in the get static paths
will just result in a 404.
if fallback true then it won't result in
a 404
if the page doesn't exist it will fall
back
to a version of the page on the first
request of the path
so fallback false we'll just be like i
don't have it
it's not in my list of static paths
404 fall back true it will say wait let
me go look
let me go see if it's there and then
re-render it for us
and then while it's getting that path it
will add it to the get static paths
because maybe you didn't
build again or whatever it is but it
will add it to your paths
and put it up here so that is get static
paths for us
it is getting a collected list of all
of the paths that this dynamic route can
be
so we will save that and let's work on
get static props
now the reason why we use grok right
here is that you can shape
the data structure that next wants for
this right and grock
so we don't have to do all these like
well if it's not a slug if it is here
just get that slug and set
it two params all right so now with the
get static props
because we have set params to the the
slug the current slug
we are going to pass that into our get
static props because we need those
params
and the slug that was clicked on in
order to pull out the
the correct content for whatever they've
clicked on your user
so we're going to destructure our params
in here
oops and then
open this up and do const
slug is equal to params
okay so the params that we're sending in
is now our slug
so now we need to look at the recipe
data from sanity
and so we'll do const recipe
away sanity client dot fetch because
we've already written our query we're
just going to pull in what we named it
recipe query and then we want that
slug so we want the slug but
the content from that particular slug
and then we will return
props like we did in the last file
and it will be set to data
which is the recipe and that is it
so we're going to save that now let's
talk about this
so now we can find the slug inside of
pram so the const slug params
if we had called our file instead of the
destructuring
slug if we did a destructuring recipe
then the param would be
const recipe is equal to params
so that const slug is matching up with
this right here the naming of the file
so you can name that anything we just
chose slug so we took
this this grot query
and pass it to our client like
this okay the sanity client
fetch and then in the studio
the slug is stored as slug dot current
because it wants to be able to store
previous slugs in the future
so the current one whatever it is is
slug dot current and that's what is
being saved as in the studio
so our function get static pass works in
a similar way to get static
props only you want to export an array
of the params
that is slugs that you want next to
build
so we do the grot query for this as well
and that that is next next is
really great with like being able to
build out really big
applications but with two
very very powerful functions um get
static paths and get static props
um we're getting our paths
and we're getting those props out of
those paths and then we're going to pull
this up
into one recipe and use it up here and
send it to our template
so from here you could take your next js
application and
grab any kind of data grab a large
amount of paths
and put in the temple however you need
but this is a great starting point
because it kind of covers
a little bit of a lot i'm very excited
to see what
can be built on from this point
especially from
these two great powerful functions that
next has given us okay so the way
someone once described both of these to
me
get a static path and get static props
is get static paths
is like knowing the address of every
house
in a neighborhood the aesthetic props is
knowing
the people who live in those houses and
what they ate for breakfast
so the path to the house
and all the houses and the data and
content
within those paths so i hope that makes
sense
um these are both really powerful and
good to know
now let's move on and let's get our
content
put into our one recipe
okay now something that i realized that
i did that we
don't need to do is at the top in our
query we actually don't need
because remember from index.js we had
the url4 that took care of pulling out
that url from the main image
so we can just do just main image but we
will destructure
the ingredient down here to get the name
out
and all this is good to go and one last
thing i do want to mention
is we are passing the grok params as an
object as the second argument of the
fetch
function so we have our params
coming in here setting the slug and
using that
here as the second argument
that matches up with what's happening
right here
this slug so we have a lot of params
going around
but grock pram's
second argument and it matches up to
that slug that is trying it's trying to
find
and yeah so what we need to do next is
we need to grab
all of the props that we are getting out
of this
and put it up into our
one recipe function so let's
work on this part of the file so because
it is set
to data we are going to pull up here
data and then open this up and we're
going to do
const recipe
is equal to data and then down here
we are going to be doing the return
and let's build out our template so
let's start with an article
and within that we will have an h1 let's
come out of
that and we'll have our main section
that will have an image
and a div next we'll have an
unordered list and then the list items
we
will
put there and this unordered list will
be the
list of ingredients and like how many of
each ingredient like a cup or
a fourth cup a gram but that will all go
in here
and then outside of this unordered list
we are going to have
and i'll just say instructions here
uh because we're not going to build that
yet but that's where our instructions
will go
so yeah let's start on the h1 the h1
we're going to have
be recipe.name
so let's bring in recipe.name let's save
that and let's see if that is being
pulled out
so if we click on that nothing happens
because we haven't changed in index.js
we have not
changed this link so it still thinks
it's supposed to be going home
so let's fix that so let's delete all
that
and then we'll do curly braces with back
ticks and we're going to do slash
recipes because we are following this
path so it's diving into this folder
recipes
and then we're going to do
recipe dot slug dot current
save that and let's see what happens so
if we click on something
404 oh because if you look up here
i miss a slash and so now it's just like
that whole
thing it's going correct but it's not
fully correct because we need
that slash now let's go try so let's go
back home
let's click on pineapple smoothie and
now we get
instructions here and pineapple smoothie
so this
is the part that is being pulled out
and it's working our data is working and
we have
our list item but instructions here
that is hard coded that's not our data
yet but this is being pulled out
if we go back and go to mango smoothie
mango smoothie should pop up and it does
all right so let's keep building out
this template and let's get
going on that so not index but here in
slug
so in the unordered list we do want to
map over our ingredients
and the amount of each ingredient so
let's do
recipe dot ingredient if it's there
then map over it and we'll do
ingredient we'll come out of that
open that up and let's take these three
and move it underneath
this li perfect let's save that
and then within our li we're going to
give it a key
that is equal to ingredient dot
key so that will go there
let's open this up and this is where
we're going to pull in
the amount
of the ingredient so we have whole
number unit fraction
so we want to pull all that out it will
be
ingredient and if there's an ingredient
pull out a whole
number let me just copy all this
and then we're going to do a break here
paste that so we'll do whole number
we'll do
fraction we'll do
unit and then we will do
ingredient dot name so notice how this
one is just
well these three are ingredient whole
number
but this is ingredient ingredient name
it's because
we come up here it goes ingredient whole
number
unit fraction all that but we also have
ingredient that is de referencing
the ingredient and grabbing out the name
and
i just want to also point out i did
update this to say
key now so we're using the key now if we
come back down here
we're going to add just a space
right there so everything's not so
crammed and we have the name
and let's pull in the
main image so same as index we'll do
source
equal to and we're going to do url4
and it will be recipe if there's a
recipe then get the main
image and
the url of that image now if we save
that
we should have a lot of content on the
page
we do okay so we have the image
and we have one cup mango
if we went to pineapple smoothie same
thing
and we have all of that so that is great
it's looking good
okay so then we can come back here
and we have the name we have the image
let's do the instructions part so like
we pulled in from above
portable text let's now use it so i'm
going to come down here and i'm going to
replace this h3
with portable
text so portable text what it does is it
maps over those blocks
that we saw and transforms them into
react components
and that if we want to we can override
and use our own customized
components to replace any of the default
behavior with that being said
let's pull in our blocks let me again
show you what our block
content looks like so if i go back into
the studio
so pineapple smoothie if i come down
here we have our instructions
if i click on these three dots and do
inspect
we see in instructions type
block and we have you just kind of
collapse
some of these so we have three
items in the instructions that are block
type okay this first one
so see how it says type block if you go
into children
the marks the text is put all
ingredients into a blender
so that's our first block our second
block
is in children blend on high for one
minute
and our third block is serve chilled
so it's grabbing all of those blocks
and this is what we see here but the
rich text editor this is where we edit
all of that
and we can do like bold italic and it
will show up that way on our front end
so it will take that styling with it now
if we go back
portable text takes in blocks
and then it will take in recipe
dot instructions save that and we should
get
all of the instructions blocks
and that should be displayed so let's go
back
to cap's kitchen so at cap's kitchen
we'll go click on pineapple smoothie
and we should see our blocks
and they're displayed just as we had in
that rich text editor
strong emphasis and yeah if i wanted to
bold the chilled part
bold publish that
and then there it is sort of chilled
with bold strong until and that
is our template now what is left
is styling because very large image
and then that so what we're going to do
is we're going to put them next to each
other
so let's do on main
let's do an article we'll do class
name is equal to recipe
on main we'll do
class name is equal to content
and then this div
we will do breakdown
this unordered list will get a class
name
of ingredients
and then this list item will get a class
name
of ingredient so singular
and
portable text we'll get
a class name that is
instructions save that and
something that i forgot on our images is
we want to have alt
on our images so we'll do alt is equal
to
recipe dot name yeah
and then we should do that on index.js
right where's my image right here
we'll do alt equal to whoops
it's equal to recipe dot
name save that
and yeah
let's go style and then we'll go look at
it so we'll go to global css
okay so we're going to come down here
and we're going to start with
recipe the h1 and we'll do
font size is 48 pixels
font weight bolder
color we'll do
hash 00 and margin bottom
15 pixels all right and then underneath
this
we will do content
open that up and display grid
grid let me pull this up we'll do that
oops okay one fr
and one fr so they're going to share the
space
and then we'll do a gap around them at
30 pixels
coming out of that the recipe
image will get border 0.5 pixels
solid and then hash 444.
then breakdown
breakdown is going to have display
grid grid
template columns at 1 fr and three fr so
like
one and then three so like more space
underneath here we'll give it a gap of
10 pixels
and a border of 0.5 pixels solid
hash 444. underneath
breakdown we'll do the ingredient
so not plural or ingredient so
plural and then we'll do list style
none so it takes away that that uh that
bullet point
that comes up we'll do padding
at 25 pixels and 10
25 pixels and 10 pixels so all sides and
then
border right
0.5 pixels solid hash 444
and then we have ingredient so now we're
at the singular one
ingredient and we'll do margin
bottom of 15 pixels
and then the last one is instructions
and we'll do padding at 15 pixels
save that and it should look
pretty nice let's go look
and it does i like how that looks so
we got our image we've got our
ingredients and like how much and then
the
instructions let's go back to cap's
kitchen
let's click on mango smoothie and it
should have the same
stuff and it does and looks great
um yeah so you can
style however you'd like but this is
just kind of like
a good start to styling a recipe
page there's one thing i do want to add
that
we haven't done yet you don't have to do
this but i added it to mine
so i definitely want to show you all if
you go to hero patterns
here you can pick fun backgrounds
and let's say you pick this piano one
you can change
the color of the foreground change the
color of the background
and the opacity of it
then you grab the url
i already have one so i'm just gonna put
it in but this is where you can grab it
um you would just get background image
this whole thing
and use that so
i'm just going to grab that that css
styling i'm just going to put it in
if you want to add it you definitely can
it is
my background image and
it is little foods
very fitting for a recipe app but that
is just something that if you'd like to
add you can
i think it's really nice it's just like
a very slight opacity
and yeah so you can add that if you want
all right so slug.js is
built out we have
pulled in all the things that we need we
have our query and remember i updated
this
and the main image so be sure to do that
and in here we're passing in our data
using it throughout
our template mapping over our
ingredients
and the whole number and the fraction
all that
we have our portable text and then we
have get static paths and get static
props
so with all that being done we are
really using
the power of next js and this file can
really be built on you can have
a lot of content going in through these
two functions
and then passing it into your your
template
a lot can happen with the get sag paths
and the get static props with that being
said i do want to move on to
api routes within next.js so how we're
going to do that is we're going to add a
like button so
a user on the front end can click a like
button and it will
update a number on the front end
and then it will save to the content
link and
we'll be able to see that in the studio
an updated like number
so somebody clicks on the button it says
plus one or one more than what it was
before
and then it patches that to the content
lake
and then updates the sanity studio so
the front end facing of it
so let's get working on that and let's
get
our api route set up in next
okay so let's build that like button we
do want to have
some interaction with our users and the
like button i think
would be a perfect addition to this
application
so that button will live right
underneath the
pineapple smoothie right underneath the
name of the recipe
in the slug.js version of that
recipe all right so
we need to add some things because every
time someone hits
the like button it will be like a little
button with a heart on it and every time
they hit it
it will increase for them they'll see
the number increase
but then that will save to the content
like
and then that will update in our sanity
studio
so we need to add that to our studio so
that it can update somewhere
and show us the current live
number of our likes so we're going to go
into within studio schemas
go into recipe and at the very bottom
right under instructions we're going to
add name
is likes
title likes and then
type will be number
awesome and then we're going to set an
initial value so outside the fields
array we'll do
initial value and set that equal to
likes is zero
awesome okay so let's go look in our
studio to see if there
is a likes spot now
so we'll come here and it should be
in our recipe because that's where we
put it and sure enough
there's likes so every time it's clicked
and it's saved to the content link
it will reflect here and we'll be able
to see that
then the last thing we need to do is add
it to slug.js into
our query so save that
so now we're going to be working with
api routes within next.js so api routes
will live still where all the other page
routes are
under pages so these are our other
routes
api is where all of our api routes will
live so when we did create next app
it gave us the hello.js1 we're going to
create our own one
so under api do new file and we'll do
handle
dash like js now
api routes will because they are
serverless functions they are node
functions
they will run on the server side so
every time this is hit it's going to be
running pages
api it's running the api route of our
application
so we need to pull in a couple things we
need to do a couple things in here but
let's take it one step at a time
and we'll do it together so we do need
to import
the sanity client
from
libsanity awesome and then right below
this we need to do sanityclient.config
open that up and token right here
token here so right here we're going to
have a
write token so every time it's clicked
saved to the content link
it will write to our client and update
the studio so we will get that token in
just one moment but let's continue on
with this
serverless function so then we'll do
export
default async
function like
button handler and we'll do rec
so request and res response open that up
and we'll do const id we'll set the id
to json.parse
rack.body oh
i forgot the equal equals
great and then we'll do const data
equal to await sanity client
and then we're going to chain on a
number of things that allow
for us to do what we need this like
button to do so the sanity client can do
a number of things and as we chain on
some of the different functionality of
it we will be able to update
our like count i'm going to pull up the
sanity client information on the this
package but we are using the next sanity
one
i just wanted to show that it also can
be used in the
sanity slash client
now if we come down here i want to take
us to
the patch update document okay so some
of these
we will be using so let's talk about
them we will be using patch so document
id to patch we will be pulling out
the id we will be using
increment increment field by count so
every time someone clicks on it
it's incremented by one and then we will
do commit because we want to commit that
we'll do a catch so any errors
we're also going to be using right here
set if missing
so set if missing we will set likes to
zero
if there is if it's missing if the
information's missing
and then yeah that's all i wanted to
cover here now let's go write it out
in our serverless function so right here
we'll do dot patch and we'll do the id
we'll do dot set if missing
and this we will set likes to zero
then we will do increment we want this
to be likes is one so it will increment
by one every time it's clicked
and then we'll do commit because we want
to commit everything
and then we'll do catch error
oops catch error
and then console. log
error awesome so that is
our chain for making this work
then we're going to do res.status will
be 200
dot json and then
likes will be data dot likes
all right so i just wanted to also point
out that we won't be doing
any checks so we won't be doing a lot of
security here um we will be keeping
our token saved safe in an environment
variable
now to make this finally
work we do need this token so remember
when we were in
manage and we went we saw
our our project id
we updated the course origins here
is where that is where we're also going
to get our token
so let's go here and go to manage
sanity.io switch to new version
and then go back to our project
so we're going to click on settings and
then under
api settings we're going to click on
tokens
and here we're going to add an api token
so we can name it we'll do next recipe
up like i have right here
next recipe app and it will be read and
write
save that and here is the token by the
time this goes live
this token will be deleted but this is
what it looks like i wanted to
make sure you all saw this i'm going to
copy this token
and this is what we're going to use
in our env file
so we're going to come back here so
let's collapse all of these
and we're going to do new file we'll do
dot env dot local and in here we're
going to call it
and here we're going to call it sanity
write
token equal that and paste that in
save that and we're come to we're going
to come to our get ignore
and then here we're going to add
env.local
so when we push it to github this will
not be pushed because we do want to keep
this token
safe but that's how it will look and
again be sure to put it under your git
ignore
now with that being said
let's go add that token
so this will now be process
dot env dot sanity
write token save that
okay so now our token is being used here
and last thing we need to do is
create that like button and get it to
use
all this functionality that we wrote
that we wrote out
so we'll go into slug so now that we are
in the slug we need to
add state because we are going to be
using
so import use
state from react
and then down here we are going to
[Music]
set our state for our likes so that
our state can be updated as the user
interacts with the like button
so we'll do const
likes and set likes and we'll set that
equal to use
state and if there's data
and if there's a recipe get the likes
likes okay and then underneath that
we're going to write out a
function that uses our
serverless function that we just made so
we're going to do const
add like equal
async
open that up const res
await and then we're gonna fetch that
slash api
slash handle like
come out of that and then within that
we'll do a method
post because we're posting we're
updating
and then body will be json.stringify
and we'll do underscore id
is recipe dot id
okay and then right outside of this
we'll do a dot catch error
and we'll do console.log error
and then underneath that we will do
const data is
equal to await res.json
and then we'll do set likes and set that
to be data.lakes okay
so now let's use this function and
let's make a button out of it
so underneath the h1 is where our
button will live so we'll do
button and then within here
we will use the likes
and we'll come out of here and we will
add a
heart save
that and within our button
let's give it a class name because we do
want to style it class
name is equal to like
button and then we'll do an on click so
whenever it's clicked
use that function that we just wrote out
the add like one up here all right
so let's go style it and then let's go
look at it
so in styles as you guessed global.css
let's add our like button styling
so we'll do dot like button
and then we'll do font size at 18 pixels
display is flex align
items center outline
none we'll do background of none
so we can see our fun background behind
it and then
we will do border radius so just giving
it
a little rounded edges edge
five pixels border one pixel
solid hash four four four
padding we'll do six pixels
and 12 pixels so all sides and then
margin
bottom 40 pixels and cursor
pointer so people know that it's
clickable
okay oh and then i didn't save this
let's save that
and we should have a button let's
restart our servers
because we we did a lot
so let's restart sanity to end it
control
c and then i'm gonna do sanity start
and then for my next app same thing
not sanity start uh npm run dev
okay so that is now running now let's go
back and we see a
button um let's click on it and let's
see what happens
and we get a one okay
now the big trick is was
are was it saved to the content like and
was our sanity studio updated
and it was okay so everything's working
and pineapple smoothie now has one like
and if i click
here again we should get two and we
should have
two okay so our serverless function our
api route is all working
and if we go to mango smoothie it should
have nothing
and then we should have let's go to
mango
smoothie click
one and one okay so all of that is
functioning correctly
now our users are able to interact with
our application
and um yeah we have api
api routes set up with our next
application it's saving
the the like every single time it's
clicked
to the content link sending that to our
sanity studio and
updating our likes field so
it looks good now the last thing we want
to do is we want to set up
preview so for content editing
it's a very quick live preview of edits
happening in the studio
onto the front end but let's get that
all set up all right so the last thing
we need to do
before we push to github and deploy this
is we are going to add preview so you
might remember
in top of this file the use preview
subscription that came from the
sanity.js
file so now we are going to use it
so we are going to be adding a couple of
lines of code but those lines of code
will do
a bunch of stuff for us so the way we're
going to use this hook this preview
subscription
is that if the preview is enabled we
want to start listening to
changes that's done in the content link
and then replace whatever content you
have on the page with that content
and we can do that since next uses react
so let's start with adding these lines
to our slug.js file
okay so we're going to come down here
and we are going to pass
in preview preview will come from down
at the bottom of our page so in the get
static props
we are going to add in preview
is true all right and then come back
up here to
at the top of the one recipe function
and we're going to add
const data
and then set that to recipe is equal to
and we're going to use
preview subscription
and then we're going to use the recipe
query so that query that we wrote above
open this up and
we're going to set params to
slug which is going to be data dot
recipe if there's a recipe
the slug dot current and we're going to
do initial
data set that to data and then enabled
preview all right so let's talk about
these so params here works the same as
the client this is where we can
dynamically add
information to the query to find the
correct recipe
by its slug and then initial data is the
data it should return
before the real time updates start up
so typically this is the data that comes
through the props via get static props
and then enabled here this controls if
the preview should be activated or not
so if you plan to put this to production
you need to have a way for editors
that are logged in to be able to
activate the preview
so that can happen through setting up an
api route that redirects you to this
page
with preview enabled or some other way
but next js does have a guide on how to
set this up and you can of course
join sanity slack community and ask
there too
we're just going to enable it from get
static props for now
and then we set up the index.js file to
also be set up this way
but we are only going to be focusing on
the slug.js
side of things so the clue here is to
make sure that the shape of the object
you pass to initial data
is the same that you get out of use
preview subscription
and that's pretty much it so with all
this
setup behind the scenes this use preview
subscription
this hook knows if you're logged into
your sanity project
and if you are and preview is set to
true
then it goes and it fetches your whole
content link in one request
and then puts it into your browser's
memory then it uses one additional
request
to set up a listener that creates a
real-time connection to your hosted
content link
and updates the browser whenever there's
been a change and we will see that
live here in this course so then it
re-renders the page
component with the new content so that
means it doesn't
have to do a ton of api requests so
since it uses this real-time connection
you don't have to think about extra
authentication for the preview as long
as your editors are logged into their
sanity studio
so this is also why we needed to enable
authenticated requests when we set up
our course setting so
you should only enable this for domains
that you control the code on
that's why we did here localhost 3000
and when we
when we deploy it we'll add that
deployed url
it's also possible to add the preview
experience to the sanity studio
so that your editors can access it in a
more seamless way
okay and then the last thing we need to
do is we need to remove
right here this const recipe data
because now
that is being taken care of right
here for us so we got rid of that line
and now that's all here so be sure to
delete that line
that was down here okay now that that is
all saved let's go check it out
okay so i'm going to pull my studio tab
out
and then let's just bring this over and
we'll just do half screen for each
for the next side and the studio side
okay so let's see this
do live preview updates so we'll click
into mango smoothie
and here we have mango smoothie the like
button is still working
we have two if we click again it will be
three
and that is updating down here
so that's all happening but watch this
so if i click into recipe name
and right away we see the update
happening
so like i explained all before what's
happening behind the scenes now we can
actually see what's happening
so if i wanted to say
yogurt and mango smoothie
there we go we we do that and then we
can do like let's add an item
oh we'll just do pineapple um we'll do
so see how pineapples showed up we'll do
half
of a cup of pineapple
and as i'm working in the studio we're
seeing that live update so then if we go
to
pineapple smoothie same thing we do
recipe
click on pineapple smoothie and
we'll do maybe we don't want any mango
so we'll delete that
remove it and right away it is removed
from our list
so that is the preview that
we have hooked up it was using
or it is using the use preview
subscription that we added to
our sanity.js file and to recap
what is happening here is it is saving
the changes to our content link and
replacing whatever content
you have on the page with that content
and
because next is react we can do that
so yeah using the use preview
subscription creates this
live preview update for us all right so
now we have our entire
application let's make this big again
we have our entire application set up we
have cap's kitchen taking us home
we have two recipes and if we add it it
would just keep tacking them on to this
page we have pineapple smoothie and we
have a like button that every time we
hit
it patches to our content link and that
will then
update our content in our sanity studio
we have our pictures we have our
ingredients we have our instructions
now from here we go back we can go into
mango smoothie and we have
our information here as well and it's
laid out all very nicely and
if you joined me in adding this
background
image uh maybe you picked something else
but
i picked the popsicles and donuts and
food
so i thought it was very fitting for a
recipe app and yeah
it is all set up it's all good to go and
this is a great starting point for any
of your next applications
we did uh dynamic routes
we did regular routing index we did api
routes
we did styling we did a
content back-end with sanity we saved
everything to our content link
and pushed it all to the sanity studio
now what we need to do
it needs to be pushed to github and it
needs to be deployed
so let's work on that and let's get that
url so we can send
our new next.js app to all of our family
members so they can see
all of our cool recipes and they can add
likes to the ones that are their
favorites
so let's get working on that so before
we move on from preview i did want to
mention
we haven't really dealt with draft
documents
in the code and how sanity currently
works with draft documents
so when you hit the like button when
you're editing a document you won't see
the number reflected in the studio
it's of course possible for us to add a
bit of code and logic to deal with this
but the point here is to learn about
next api routes
so once we added preview because
sanity created a draft document things
might get a little
off with the likes um you can remove the
preview
part of this if um you are not
interested in learning
further about this but if you are
definitely keep it in and definitely go
ask questions in the sanity slack
community
if you'd like to get get that all set up
but um we wanted to cover next
api routes and by keeping it simple we
didn't
dive too much into how draft documents
are handled but
just wanted to cover that and let you
know that if you need further help
definitely hit the sanity slot community
and
remove it if you just don't want it now
the last thing we need to do
is in slug.js and i wanted to point this
out so we have
fallback set to true so because fallback
is set to true i wanted to point
something out that
next wants from us i want to paste this
in
we need to create so this is the
document or the docs
fallback pages because it's set to true
because we have that in our code we do
need to
have a loading page so as it's getting
the data
if the first time it runs there is none
let's have a loading page
and then it can continue running and
then put in our data
so we're going to add a line kind of
like this
if the page is not yet generated it will
display this loading page
so we're going to go back to our slug.js
so right here we're going to do
const router is equal to use router
and underneath we'll do if
router dot is fall back
open that up and return div that says
loading dot dot and then we need to
bring in the use
router above come down here and we'll do
import
use router from
next router and that is
it that's all we need all right so to
get this now pushed to github
we are going to come into our terminal
we're going to do get init
all right and then we are going to go to
our github
so go to your github and click on new
for new repository
and here we are going to name our
repository so that's where i'm at we're
going to do next
recipe app come down here i'll make it
public so
all of you can see this code and then
come to the very bottom and click
create repository so it's going to
create it
and we've already done the get in it we
are just going to follow down these
instructions
so git commit dash m get commit
dash m we'll do first commit
and there's all of our file files and
folders that
need to be committed get branch dash
m main git branch dash m
main awesome and then back here we are
going to
copy this whole thing so that we can
direct it to the correct repository
hit enter so we're going to add all
these so we're going to do git
add space period to add all of them get
status
and we see all them that are added in so
then let's do git
commit dash m recipe
app hit enter and we'll do git push
origin main and that is going to push
and now if we go back
to this we should see
recipe app so now we have all of our
code
saved into our next recipe app
repository
so let's go deploy it so let's do our
back end
first so to deploy our sanity back in we
are going to i'll just add another one
here
i actually don't need to pull that down
we will cd into studio
and we are going to run the command
sanity
deploy it's going to ask us a series of
questions
so studio hostname this needs to be
unique um we'll do
uh caps
kitchen for mine uh so make sure you
choose one that's not
cap's kitchen because that one is taken
and it's available so lucky for me so
it's building that out
now if you wanted to undeploy this you
could do sanity
undeploy and that would refer all this
but while that deploys
we are going to have our studio now live
at cap's kitchen
dot sanity.studio and we will have a
deployed version
of our back end of our studio
uh our content link is going to be
living here
and it is ready success
so we could click on this but i want to
go type it in
caps kitchen.sanitylstudio
capskitchen.sanity.studio
enter and
here is our deployed studio
so we have all of our stuff chef
ingredient
recipe everything that we put in there
is
now deployed now whenever you need to
like
update something or you're working on a
team if they have access to
this studio if they have access to the
content link that is cap's kitchen
then they will have access here and then
they can go in they can edit stuff
you can see your team working there's
the presence api up here
um their avatars would show up if
they're hanging out um
but yeah that is our deployed back end
now let's go deploy our front end so
we're going to come to for sale i've
already
logged in and i already have searched
for the
repository so all you got to do is pick
the organization
and search for um your repository so i
did
the next recipe app because that's what
we named it and i have found it
now we are deploying to versailles it's
a deployment platform
for front-end developers so we are
deploying our front end to versailles
and let's see how this goes so we're
going to click
import
now project name we can name this
anything we want i'm going to keep it
next recipe app
you can change this here it is root
directory
now we don't want to change any of these
these will just stay as is but
environment variables
we do need to bring in that right token
so i'm gonna do sanity
write token and let's go get that
so it is underneath our env local
let's copy this whole thing and then
come back here
and paste that in we're going to add it
now it's encrypted and it's in there so
now even though the dot unv
was not pushed to github
next is vercell is going to see it
because we've added it here
and yeah we're good to go so i'm going
to hit
deploy and fingers crossed everything
goes
well and we'll have a deployed app that
we can
send the url to all of our family
members and they can see all of our
recipes
and they can like all of the recipes
because they're going to like them no
matter what they're going to be
delicious
and it's deploying fetching
the source code building
so we could be watching the build and
it looks like it's going well
okay so it's continuing to build and it
should be
not too much longer and we will have our
deployed
front end and back-end we already have
the back-end and congratulations
okay so our app is now deployed
we can hit visit and it should open up a
new tab
and it has our whole application
and we can click into things and we can
see
ah what do we need to do we need to tell
manage.sanity.io that this is a
trusted url so i'm going to copy this
i'm going to go to manage
and in here studio settings
course origins and we need to add this
one so notice how our sanity.studio was
added
um we don't need to worry about that but
we need to add the versailles side so
paste that in there allow credentials
save
and oh yeah there it is awesome we'll
come back to cap's kitchen
and if it all worked then we should be
able to click in and there we go
all right so now everything is working
everything is deployed if i hit
the like button and then i go to
my deployed cap's kitchen what did i hit
like on
pineapple smoothie and i go to pineapple
smoothie
i should see four four likes awesome
so everything is working and we have it
to github we have it
deployed to versailles for the front end
sanity for the for the back end
and you can use that url you can do
with this app as you'd please but you do
now have a good knowledge base on
next js so you can take this however far
you want
or build another next.js application and
take it however far you want and yeah i
think it turned out pretty great
first of all thank you thank you for
sticking around
thank you for going through all this
with me and great work everyone on
this amazing next js application that
we've built
we've looked at how to set up next and
the overall structure
we've looked at how next uses file based
routing we've explored how we can do
performant linking between views in next
we have touched on styling and how to
change the meta tags
and how to deal with static assets now
our recipe app wouldn't be much if we
didn't use any recipes
so we used next powerful data fetching
functions
get static props and get static paths to
handle getting that recipe content for
us
and pre-render whatever recipes we had
to give all of our visitors
a faster and neater experience now we
have also learned about how we can get
up and running with structured content
using sanity.io so we have configured
sanity studio to make
a custom way of entering the recipe info
into a structured manner
so that we can pull it from our content
link and put it onto our next js
app we have also learned about next.js
api routes
and that lets us quickly set up
serverless functions to handle business
logic for us
without any configuration we use some
business logic to make a like button
remember and that patches an integer in
the recipe document to our content link
and we added that interactive feature to
our app in about 10 minutes
so really great and lastly we set up
real-time preview
in less than 10 lines of code which lets
authenticated
editors see how the content is presented
before pushing it to production this was
possible because sanity.io's content
link
is built to be real-time from the ground
up and because next.js uses react that
lets us trigger
re-renders in the browser when something
changes
now next steps next next steps to
advance so you should know enough to
do useful stuff with nexjs there's still
a lot that we haven't really touched too
much on
and although the people behind next.js
spend a lot of time to make it
performant
there's still things that we can do to
optimize it we haven't done too much
with the seo of this app
but there are many ways to leverage
next.js and the structured content we
get out of sanity
to make that happen and we have barely
touched on the surface of what we can do
with the combination of
serverless functions api routes and the
content link
both in terms of adding interactive
functionality but also comes to making
it secure and resilient in a production
app so if you want me to make a more
advanced course on next.js let me know
in the comments below
again thank you so much for hanging out
thank you so much for
building this app with me i think it
turned out really good i like it
but i'm excited to see where your
applications go
how you design it because my css doesn't
have to be your css
and where you take this recipe app to
so if you'd like you can send it my way
i am on the slack
for sanity and you can also find me on
twitter
at copej underscore okay my dms are open
and i would love to see
your deployed recipe applications
again thank you so much for hanging out
and i will see you around